[Musique]
aujourd'hui les républicains sont
rassemblés pour bâtir la france de
demain une france plus juste
notre nation est belle lorsqu'elle
laisse une place à chacun la france est
belle lorsqu'elle sait tendre la main
aux plus fragiles de nos concitoyens aux
français en situation de handicap aux
victimes de violences conjugales à
celles et ceux de nos concitoyens que la
vie a meurtri nous espérons une france
tourner vers l'avenir pour innover
préserver notre environnement faire
progresser notre société transformer nos
modes de consommation pour mieux
soutenir notre agriculture nationale la
france ce beau pays doit porter à
nouveau un espoir c'est ce projet pour
lequel les républicains s'engage
[Musique]